research fraud refers to cases where
data were either fabricated or falsified
to provide false support for the
researcher's hypothesis
fabrication means the data were never
collected but were made up
falsification means existing data were
illegitimately altered including
manipulating research materials
images data equipment or processes
falsification also includes changing or
omitting data or results in such a way
that the research is not accurately
represented
for example a person might falsify data
to make it fit with the desired
end result of a study
in 1998 physician andrew wakefield
published a study in the lancet
claiming that his research indicated a
connection between autism and the
measles mumps rubella vaccine
this research was highly respected and
undermine public confidence in the
vaccine
leading to many parents refusing the
shot
ultimately this led to increases in the
number of cases of measles
and mumps in the u.s and europe with
some areas reporting very dangerous and
widespread outbreaks
when faced with an investigation in 2010
it was revealed that wakefield
and his colleagues had altered facts
about the children in their study
and wakefield had even been paid off by
a lawyer planning to sue the
manufacturer of the vaccine
the british general medical council
found wakefield guilty of fraud and
misconduct
in 2006 korean researcher huang wusuk
was found to have fabricated a series of
experiments in stem cell research
a field in which he was once considered
one of the pioneering experts
he was previously famous for his two
science journal articles in which he
reported success in creating human
embryonic stem cells through cloning
but is now infamous for his massive case
of fraud and scientific misconduct after
it was revealed that much of his stem
cell research had been faked
huang was charged with embezzlement in
bioethics law violations
for which he was sentenced to a two-year
suspended prison sentence and barred
from engaging in stem cell research by
the south korean government
as well as fired from his position with
seoul national university
however huang continues to lead research
in creating embryonic
stem cell lines from cloned pig embryos
and his lab has been actively publishing
manuscripts on pubmed
in january 2014 kuruko abakata from the
raiken center for developmental biology
in kobe
japan published two papers describing
the method
called stimulus-triggered acquisition of
pluripotency in nature
but they were retracted in july after
nature discovered that the papers
included plagiarized writing
misidentified images
and misreported data haruko abakada the
lead author
who performed the studies and wrote the
manuscripts was found guilty of
falsifying data
biologist yoshiki sasai leader of the
reichen research group
was a co-author on both papers he was
criticized for his poor supervision
during the investigation sasai committed
suicide at the raiken center
in 2016 a group of researchers from
university malaya was found to duplicate
the images of cells in the photos
contained in their research article
the researchers were later found to have
published the same results three times
in three different journals the authors
are almost all from malaysia
and not the same on these three
publications
yet all three papers have seen two
corresponding authors sacramente
a professor at the department of
molecular medicine at the university of
malaya in kuala lumpur and the first
author
his phd student nima sammy
both fabrication and falsification are
serious forms of misconduct
because they result in a scientific
record that does not accurately reflect
observed truth
first of all the scientific literature
is contaminated with false empirical
data
this alone holds back scientific
progress
researchers might pursue a line of
research that seems promising but is in
fact baseless
honest researchers see their projects
fail to replicate promising results
they might incorrectly conclude this is
due to their personal lack of research
skills
the project might be abandoned without
the failed replications ever coming to
light
secondly precious funding resources that
could have been spent on valid avenues
of research
are spent on fraudulent research and
related projects that build on it but
are in fact less promising than they
seem
thirdly once fraud is exposed the
reputation and credibility of the field
including the majority of researchers
who do have integrity
is severely damaged this can result in
more difficulty to obtain funding in a
general area where fraud has been
exposed
this puts honest researchers who have
the bad luck to be in a related field at
a disadvantage
why do scientists commit fraud overall
academic fraud is rare which makes it
all the more shocking when a major case
is uncovered
to the public it may seem mind-boggling
that scientists would go to such lengths
to deceive in an ideal world
scientists work together to make
incremental discoveries that add to the
body of knowledge in a field and are
recognized for quality work
in reality the world of science can be
cutthroat and isolating with little
oversight
stem cell research is certainly not the
only research field with a fraud problem
but it has all the right elements to
motivate dishonesty
it's a cutting edge field with the
potential to discover treatments for
human diseases
it attracts highly competitive people
who are all scrambling to make the next
big discovery
and that discovery must be made written
and published before any competitors can
catch up
add that to an academic culture that
places ever rising pressure
on researchers to churn out publications
in order to land jobs or tenure
especially publications in high-impact
journals like nature and science
and you begin to see why researchers
resort to cutting corners or massaging
their data
in 2014 nobel prize winner randy
schechmann spoke out against publishing
in prestigious journals
saying that they contributed to
unhealthy research practices
and advised people to boycott them
barring acceptance at a major journal
academics must still publish somewhere
and this pressure has created a market
for yet another type of academic fraud
predatory journals
fraud cases are invariably accompanied
by reluctance
or even unwillingness to share data and
research information with others
unless researchers are challenged or
even required to be open and transparent
fraud can be tempting in an academic
climate where publishing positive
confirmatory results is held in high
regard
certain instances of fraud can be easy
to spot
for example if a referee knows for a
fact that a particular laboratory does
not have the facilities to conduct the
research that was published
or if it's obvious an image looks
manipulated or is made up from several
different experiments
the data from the control experiments
might be too perfect
in such situations an investigation
would be conducted to determine if an
act of fraud was committed
to help prevent fraud most publishers
have strict policies on manipulation of
images and access to the reported data
in general digital image enhancement is
acceptable
however a positive relationship between
the original data
and the resulting image must be
maintained to avoid creating
unrepresentative data
or the loss of meaningful signals no
specific feature within an image may be
enhanced
obscured moved removed or introduced
adjustments of brightness contrast or
color balance are usually acceptable as
long as they do not obscure
or eliminate any information present in
the original
if a figure has been significantly
manipulated you must note the nature of
the enhancements in the figure legend or
in the materials and methods section
authors may also be asked to provide the
raw data in connection with a paper for
editorial review
therefore all data for a specific paper
should be retained for a reasonable time
after publication
there should be named custodian for the
data
studies undertaken in human beings such
as clinical trials have specific
guidelines about the duration of data
retention
what about unintentional error that
comes across as misconduct
according to the us office of research
integrity research misconduct does not
include honest error or differences of
opinion
but it's best never to have the
integrity of your work come into
question
as a researcher and author it is
essential to understand what constitutes
appropriate data management including
data collection
retention analysis and reporting in
accordance with responsible conduct of
research
you